so I would say this as much as like I I
agree like sake at least was a
professional okay first of all Jen and
just so the audience understands when
when you transition Jen and Josh were
very kind to me I wrote about this in my
first book and they they treated the the
transition in a very professional way
and said you know what we disagree with
you but our job is to make sure you're
ready to govern and that you guys are
successful and I'll never forget that I
I give them credit for being
very professional
um and and how and helpful because they
were
gen for what it's worth is qualified to
do that job she had served the state
department spokesman she had been on
several campaigns she'd been with Obama
um you may not like the answers and I
get it and I I don't know
couldn't jump here is not qualified to
do the job
foreign
about your old job we've talked about
this a bit before but when I watch you
how long was your stand it was pretty
seven months seven months and then
Kaylee no then Sarah Sarah then
Stephanie then Kelly right
um when I watched the last two saki who
just everything was a lie after lie
after lie and then and then this one
cringe up here I mean it is
extraordinary when you're watching her
are you pulling your hair out like how
the hell could it be this bad I get it
so press secretary you have to Def like
so I'm saying this as much as like I I
agree like sake at least was a
professional okay first of all Jen and
just so the audience understands when
when you transition Jen and Josh Norris
were very kind to me I wrote about this
in my first book and they they treated
the the transition in a very
professional way and said you know what
we disagree with you but our job is to
make sure you're ready to govern and
that you guys are successful and I'll
never forget that I I give them credit
for being
very professional
um and and how and helpful because they
were
gen for what it's worth is qualified to
do that job she had served as State
Department spokesman she had been on
several campaigns she'd been with Obama
um you may not like the answers and I
get it and I I don't know I accept the
players couldn't jump here is not
qualified to do the job yeah okay and
every single day we hear it we watch
each other she's a black lesbian for
God's sakes what do you want exactly but
that's the point is that this is the new
standard which is what box can you check
not are you qualified are you
experienced can you do and this isn't
like personal she literally was a field
operative before doing it so if she got
sent to the political Opera you know the
political Affairs office I'd say great
that makes sense she was on uh John
Edwards campaign she had done a bunch of
races in New York I get that she just
never dealt with the media before she
wasn't someone who was familiar to them
she doesn't understand the Karen feeding
um and so it would be like somebody
parachuting into you know the political
Affairs job you'd say why are you doing
that they wanted her because she checks
boxes and it's shows every day and the
thing that upsets me more than that is
the way that the White House Press Corps
nods up and down as if what she's saying
is a true and B as if she knows what
she's doing they're complicit in this
and that's the thing is that it I
couldn't get away with things that were
factually true but they would say well
technically you know the North Star was
placed a little I mean they they were
trying to find ways to slice and dice it
with Corinne she blatantly gets up there
and talks about the president's policy
led to a 90 drop in border crossings
that's patently false and yet she gets
away with it
um she talks about the president taking
more questions than shouted questions at
anyone before I mean you could hate
Donald Trump and say there's no question
every day the guy was standing next to
Marine one was the propeller went off
taking questions for you know 15 20
minutes a day Joe Biden hasn't talked to
anybody for that long what does that
tell you about the people in that room
at this point I mean they were obviously
oppositional to guys like you they're
always going to be oppositional if
there's a Republican president they're
not oppositional now and she's still
doing a pretty I would say piss poor job
yeah well because doing exactly because
I love it look I think part of it is
remember if you're on the team then
that's all that matters so she's on the
team in several ways right she's she had
been working at MSNBC she uh her partner
works at CNN she is a liberal so she
fits the they're not going to to hurt
her because they know that she's got to
end back up at CNN or MSNBC when this is
all done and that's that's what's going
to happen does it ever feel to you like
we're in just The Show Must Go On
version of all of this that's what it
feels like a lot to me like none of it
really works we all kind of know it
doesn't work we know it's all corrupt
I'm talking about politics media the
whole thing but but it sort of has to
continue because if we were to really be
confronted with the reality that none of
it works man it would it would collapse
Well it's worse it's dangerous way
perhaps it's worse than that
because if you knew how little the
government was prepared for certain
things but also I look at the threat
that China poses at this point I'm happy
they're not prepared for them well they
can only make things worse but you look
at the threat that China poses
um the rise of our debt all of these
things and say it's right there
um I always I get a kick out of this but
there was in in the first
um
uh there was a scene where Dr Evil is
going after Scott evil and he's trying
to kill Austin Powers and that first
Austin Powers movie and he sends them
down to I think be with the sharks and
Scott evil says can't we just deal he's
right there we can shoot him I have a
gun and Dr Eva says no no no we're going
to put them in the Sharks obviously
subsequently escapes and so many times
in government the solution's sitting
right in front of you you could say
can't you just solve that and they go no
no you know what we're gonna do we're
going to create this commission or we're
going to create a study and right you're
like you're just punting and I feel like
whether it's the Border China the debt
all of these issues the government just
doesn't want to act and love them or
hate them the thing that I loved about
Trump was that he would look at
something bad a trade deal and I'd been
I mean I joked about it from the podium
but I then the assistant U.S traded up
for under the last three years of bush
and we were told over and over again
well you know this this is called being
enforced this trade agreement's in force
we can't do anything about it
unfortunately we've all signed our names
Trump started to go I don't really care
it's a bad trade deal we're pulling out
an afternoon everyone's like oh and what
happened we ended up signing usmca
better deal for Wisconsin Dairy Farmers
Alabama automakers over and over again
you go is that that bad we pulled out of
Iran we pulled out I mean like we did
things the Paris climate agreement and
everyone said the the sky is going to
fall
when you're not concerned about the
Jerusalem Embassy oh my God World War
um and not only that but it went from
not causing World War to the Abraham
Accords which you know allowed for
countries that hadn't talked we have
flights going over places you just came
back from there a few weeks ago where
we now have things but somebody has to
be willing to say I don't mind
because it it's always been done this
way I'm willing to take a chance and do
it the other way or if it's better and
that's not this is you know this I'm
sorry because I Shameless self-promoter
here but this is why I'm doing what I'm
doing that to explain to people that
there are better ways to do it I watch
president Trump do it I watched the sky
not fall and so you know part of as we
do this
is you know and I
don't want to bury the lead but part of
the show is we're going to build this
all in local something that you've done
and we're going to have a section where
VIPs can tell me what do we want to hear
what it what are you guys interested in
what do you think we need more of or
less of and how do you want me to
present this or who would be a good
person to bring in or what kind of
expertise and that's the beautiful thing
about doing what I'm doing is that
through the locals Community our VIP
members can be part of this process and
say I want to know more about this why
is the primary and caucus system set up
the way it is why can't we stop the flow
of illegal immigration why is whatever
it is I might not be the best person but
I certainly know who is and that's the
other thing I might you know be able to
call in somebody and say hey I keep
getting questions from our locals
audience that they want to know more
about whatever so let me get you know
Chad Wolfe to come in and explain it
from the homeland security standpoint or
Tom Homan to come in and talk about from
a border security standpoint but I think
there are things going on to your point
that it feels like we're just doing
something the debt I mean this is insane
what's going on with our debt every year
we keep having the same conversation and
saying we can't talk about it right now
because we don't want to default but
then once we raise the debt ceiling we
forget to have the conversation and we
keep reissuing the credit card and
saying we've raised your debt limit just
please kind of don't maybe spend as much
Biden every day talks about more
spending and we're supposed to believe
that this guy is going to be concerned
about the long-term debt and debt
ceiling if you're looking for more
uncensored opinions from today's thought
leaders check out our media playlist and
if you want to watch full interviews on
a wide variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell